[Music]
hey bart
do you know who uh jess
bowen is jess who that is is
a fitness instructor and instagram
influencer
she has um a bit of a following but her
daughter
is the one that's making her life
so she's a seven-year-old named brody i
swear to god if there's another
seven-year-old richer than me i'm gonna
be pissed
they're probably rich but a
seven-year-old girl named brody
that's what you heard and latched onto
i just when i think of brody it sounds
like a
a skater boy adrian brodie oh brody yeah
just a brother
with the big nose it's kind of caught
yeah it's kind of hot adrian brody in
like a in like a unique kind of you're
kind of hot in a way yeah
who is this an actor pn pianist he owns
oh that guy
yeah is he a pianist no no he's in the
movie yeah you want the oscars so i was
right when i said actor
yeah yeah okay all right so anyway
the reason why she's making headlines is
because this little girl
can lift for real oh my god wow
what does that stunt your growth if
you're lifting as you're young no
that's a myth no yeah yeah you know
what's funny um do you guys remember
little hercules
the [ __ ] buff ass kid they did a uh
where what is he
like doing now he's just so unfit and
just regular
really if i got burnt out huh yeah from
all that i don't about
pressure as a six-year-old buff guy he's
he's like a full-grown adult now and
he's just kind of chilling
yeah an adult crazy crazy
all right so this little girl for
example she can
dead lift 94 pounds wow
and she's seven six seven years old how
much does she
damn she her body weight is 50.
50 pounds double her body weight god i
would never like
she should never get bullied in school
ever it's the barbell with 25s on each
side pretty much
ah that's a good amount it probably has
a a mini one
for her size oh yeah i can't do that
she's seven
damn 90 something so this is jackson
brody
how cute she's over that's [ __ ]
adorable dude
the cutest oh 90 really she doesn't look
like jacked
she's like a just a regular she weighs
50 pounds wow
yeah whoa oh she got good form
really good for oh that's a full-size uh
barbell right i think it's like a pvc
pipe no they're saying that she's
she's lifting uh her body or seventy
pounds
oh i think [ __ ] with my glasses but i
squatted just the bar by itself once and
i cried
[ __ ] nadine [ __ ] you what
you wanted to bargain out in a team one
time i never had trouble walking down
the stairs before that's how bad it was
just the bar yes just the bar bart it's
only 40 dollars
so that's like the same thing as like
not having the bar
no i mean that's still good 45 pounds
you're talking to someone that has like
bird arms right now
wait i'm thinking one time and then you
got sore no
you did it multiple times multiple times
oh multiple so you think like one
rep and then she left right yeah yeah
and he couldn't walk down the stairs
we lost gina thing ever i'm like that
felt like it would it would
i did a few i did a few all right i'm
gonna play a video clip of
brody i already tell she got good for
him too
is that a front squat yeah this isn't
the worst i hate that
wow that's crazy
[Music]
[Music]
so this is the one that went viral
recently that's 95.
yeah whoa she's so cute i like her oh
the cutest oh my gosh
and that's her daddy apparently
but yeah they have a very fit family
but a lot of people like like they're
hating gina first commented like
you know is that gonna stun her growth
is that is that healthy for her is that
is she at risk she looks extremely
healthy
i feel like if anything lifting weights
should like make you taller yeah so like
this is like old people right they don't
move much to get all tiny you need your
bones to like
yeah it needs like um what's the worst
stimulation stimulation
yeah what's the difference like where
where is the line between
no workout to too much and ruining your
body
like bad is there like a bad if you take
drugs
then you do it then you can really
really do it too much or not because
otherwise i feel like your body is like
okay
isn't too much relative to the
individual though that too
yeah because michael phelps used to swim
like an enormous amount of times and
like consume like ten thousand calories
or whatever
as a normal person your body like tells
you hey i i can't do it anymore well it
also
depends on your level of development so
like
countries that have academies where they
develop like fitness professionals like
china russia whatever they have their
own regimen so usually from like
three to like up to six um
it would be highly varied exercise and
coordination based because those are
things that whatever you develop there
almost like you know like the best time
to learn a language is when you're like
two or three or whatever
you can't uh that's your peak so you so
hand-eye coordination if you don't get
that down
between like three to six then from six
to 13 there's no way you're going to get
that better
what so usually people can't get better
like catching as an adult you can only
match your
previous potential so the academic like
russian academies
and that's probably what i would try to
put like taika in it's like i put them
in like swimming
gymnastics all kinds of just overall
being upside down understanding his
space
is proprioception which is like
understands body awareness then you move
into
a varied barbell sport so that's kind of
like the phase that she's in
where she's probably not trying to power
lift and she probably does a whole
variation of all kinds of exercises
which is good
but when you highly specify too early
that's when it's actually bad
so for her like if she's doing all kinds
just doing box jumps she's doing like so
like crossfit for kids is the best then
later on
as you get older that you start wanting
to specify but that's okay because now
your body is fully developed and then
you have a good base
and now it's okay but then if you age
would that be um usually after 15.
but like if she's only squatting right
now then her whole body is gonna be
developed just to squat so in terms of
overall athleticism she's gonna lose out
on that i've always seen videos have you
guys ever seen videos like
usually when you see kids it's like
they're
kind of dumb they're falling over
whatever and then you see videos like
they're not coordinated right like
their motor functions aren't that great
and then you see chinese kids they're
like cooking
on walks at two years old yeah and like
perfect motor functions in a bowl and
feeding they're eating with chopsticks
and [ __ ] like how does that happen
practice it's practice it's like i just
saw a video recently about how like you
know as a kid
uh you basically are learning how to use
each individual finger and how to move
your body and stuff
if you try just folding your pinkies in
right now without moving your other
hands
it's impossible it's not because your
muscles don't
exist there it's your brain you never
learned how to do it
you never need to move your pinky by
yourself what do you mean oh [ __ ] i
don't get it the ring for yourself
you're connected that means you're
connected your ring finger wants to move
yeah but you're also much more connected
than i am the only reason why your ring
finger wants to move when you move your
pinkies is because you've never really
moved your pinkies by itself
without the ring finger so your brain is
trying to learn how to do it
so if you practice enough you could do
it but right now my brain's getting
tired it's kind of like
using chopsticks you know some people um
that learn it in adulthood they can't
it's it's a little bit harder
but then just can't move my middle
finger without moving my ring finger
i could do that all the time i could do
this but i can't curl it the curling
part is hard
i can go flat i can't do that that's
crazy ow you're gonna be sore tomorrow
now
i won't be able to walk tomorrow oh i
can't walk
dude my my this whatever this is what is
this called her hair
palm this thing the jump that is a good
name like just this
yeah like the drumstick on my hand both
of these
or particularly this one is really sore
because of all the animal crossings
oh my god some work out i've been like
trying to like stretch it and be like
there are specialized muscles for gaming
i remember i stopped playing games for
like
eight months straight then i went to go
play on the computer after like
10 minutes my form was sore from just me
right here with my little drums oh
must have really strong clicking muscles
never hurt ever i'm good at this i've
been trained for years
it's supposed to help you out with like
um brain development too
like if you if you're used to like doing
um no just
just breaking out of a routine right so
like let's say you brush your teeth with
your
right hand sometimes do it with your
left sometimes
uh break out of routine and like it
constantly gets you to focus and
connect your nerves yep i could do both
hands
sit on your hand a little bit get a numb
you like videos oh god
i've seen videos where people do like
snap in
in a square or a z formation snap in
like a triangle and do it at the same
time
oh [ __ ] yeah oh it's like the it's like
this thing right
yeah coordination oh i do i've seen one
like with an elevator one where it's
like first floor second floor
third floor fourth floor whoa
first floor second one
goes yeah you end up wanting to do it
together i think musicians are really
good at separating their brains
like when it comes to like oh i haven't
done [ __ ] the bunny in forever
the [ __ ] is that shoot the bunny shoot
shoot the money
what yeah huh oh my this is wise it's so
hard there we go oh my god yeah i used
to do it it's like we're all high right
now oh my gosh
wait this one i can do i can what about
this one that one i can do
wait i can't even do it right now this
one you know when tycho was one this is
literally what he would do
like
that's us now at 30. he's literally like
what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you see babies like understanding their
bodies i'm like
where did they just come from where they
don't know that they had a body they're
downloading
so the first three years or wait first
three
okay so the first three years is the
hypnotic stage where you're just
downloading information you can't make
conclusions
you're getting updates taking shots
i think up until seven is that's when
you
program everything about what you think
of the world reality
first five are important like where
their logic comes from too probably huh
yeah that's why they say language is the
best to teach between one to five mm-hmm
because uh at that time you're
downloading it all as one language i'm
trying to teach this [ __ ] yeah
so if he learns like five languages
right now
that's literally just one language to
him what's crazy is i haven't taught him
chinese in a while
i just started back up again but when my
dad came over my dad's talking to him in
chinese
and he still remembers and he's replying
back in english
in spanish so my dad visited so they
don't even
my my dad doesn't even know that he's
actually communicating and he's just
laughing because he thinks he doesn't
know
he's like oh like he was asking like
what kind of fruit is this and then he
was like uber right like grapes
he's like oh uber and then my dad is
what i'm saying
actually he knows what you're saying
he's cute
it's all one language in his head yeah
that's probably why he's like oh well
spanish is the foreign one so i'll do
that one i love that
that's pretty nuts
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you